attendu pour une planète qui ne peut
plus attendre le marathon de la coque 15
est officiellement partie humanity SV
become
l'humanité est devenue une arme de
destruction massive a lancé Antonio
Guterres en appelant les négociateurs du
monde entier à ne pas se laisser berner
par les puissants lobés oublions les
rêveries de certains milliardaires il
n'y a pas de Planète B
c'est à nous de réparer le monde que
nous avons
je vous en conjure faites ce qu'il faut
agissez pour la nature
juste un Trudeau en a profité pour
annoncer que le Canada donnera 350
millions de dollars pour la protection
de la biodiversité à l'international
une annonce interrompue
par une manifestation impromptue un
rappel que les peuples autochtones sont
les plus touchés par la perte de
biodiversité et que dans un effort
sincère de réconciliation le Canada a un
devoir de résultats
je vous annonce le premier ministre du
Québec pour sa part annoncé
l'élaboration d'un plan nature avec une
enveloppe de 650 millions de dollars je
prends un langagement aujourd'hui devant
tout le monde de tout mettre en œuvre
pour atteindre une protection du
territoire québecois à 30 % d'ici 2030
voilà passer la parole aux actes de
belles paroles mais qui doivent enfin se
concrétiser croient cet homme
les actions concrètes des actions
réelles ou la biodiversité et protégée
parce que pour certains comme Annie
Sophia son identité en dépend combien
[Musique]
en 1987 on signait l'accord de Montréal
pour la protection de la couche d'ozone
un accord historique qui a porté fruits
35 ans plus tard dans la même ville
peut-on réécrire l'histoire pour
l'instant tous les scénarios sont
envisageables ici Elisa serrer
Radio-Canada Montréal